I just turned 39 and I'm embarrassed to
admit that I lived a lot of my life
without ever watching the film It's a
Wonderful Life my wife was like you've
never seen It's a Wonderful Life do you
even have worth as a human you know how
my wife talks to me and I'm like okay
I'll do it you know it's kind of long
it's like two and a half hours but by
the end I was in a puddle of tears and
if you haven't seen the movie it's
ultimately about a man who had a lot of
ups and downs in his life and eventually
reached a point where he was very
discouraged and even and an angel from
heaven was sent to actually encourage
him and tell him to keep going and his
methodology for helping him realize that
was actually to show him what life would
have been like had he never existed his
wife his kids that didn't exist because
he never did I want you to really ask
the question whose life will be impacted
by your content and whose life will miss
out